still have a zombie mold here well i
mean if he wants to play this
how are you starting more wait zombie
can play it makes it more interesting
zombie you want play
he can play but he can't talk yeah he's
our silencers
zombie zombie when are we starting the
recording we did
where is he he's right here he's going
again he's going to get a gun
is that
yeah bob you are okay in my book but
this guy
he still looks kind of shifty i'm on the
slide he's not saying anything and he's
standing completely still
yeah he doesn't look so good i don't
even know down the slide he slide
let me just pull out my shoes before oh
wait
no i don't slide down the slide yeah i'm
on a slide oh okay
it's already sliding did i mention i'm
on the slide
wait what uh how do you how did we get
to the slide
the obvious straightener oh that was the
best
hang on i'm going wait for me like a
maintenance room we need to have a race
because there's like two slides
why is it all walled off why can't i get
to the damn slide
there's some stairs by me this fire
staircase i don't care about the stairs
i don't even know where you are i'm
trying to get to the slide but it's all
walled off
i'm over here oh i found a way through
the shower area here
oh to the left of where we started i see
you mark
come to me mark man my gun is all shiny
i will
you want to have a race mat i would yes
absolutely i do
eyes my nose itches don't care must
slide
now mark we're going to set the gamble
the loser
in the race gets shot in the face okay
let's go
three okay two one whoosh
i'm sliding this is amazing
it's not that great but it's all right
this time
boosh oh geez
you turn the face that was the rules now
and then you shoot me in the face
without going i'm out of ammo
your lifeless body flopped around
how does that make you feel who's
shooting me
no he's nervous
i'm not the terrorist we're all
terrorists don't you know
ow oh wait mark wasn't a terrorist no
but you sure are zeus
that means bombs the terrorists no i've
got no
or maybe it's the rogue oh we forgot
that zombie
mold is a part of this it's currently
oh it's oh it's either bob or zombie
it's a zombie
it has to be zombies we've all killed
each other
he's coming up the other side
this is hilarious bob right there this
is
this bob no get him bob
get him if you're the tear you're just
walking along like shadily
he's just standing there zombie
defending
zombie don't be a coward face your death
like a man
where are you going zombies holding an
invisible gun on my screen
zombie's hiding like a loser
running away like a loser okay
good job zombie seems to be cornered
like a
he's loser the only place he could have
gone from where if it helps and if
you're a terrorist you can paint bring
up a raider
oh no
oh thank you guys for killing each other
we were just having fun on the slide
well yeah
until i blew yami's face off for no
reason
i thought mark was the traitor why would
you think i was a traitor
i always think you're the traitor that's
not a good mindset to have
you need to rethink your priorities you
would be the only one
why would i be the only one i don't know
because you're evil it's scary
why am i evil and scary i don't know
because you scare me
you're just raising a whole bunch of
questions here wade in fact i seem to be
a lot more suspicious of you now than
ever
what big suspicious of you yes exactly
that is a suspicious activity you're
causing much
a scene wade and i i don't like this
wait this does not bode well
creation phase yeah but we think that
you're still the traitor
because you got that face you know that
facey face that you just can't trust
you know those eyes that you look into
them
yeah whatever no the slides are mine no
one can come to the slides
it's a slight of death if anyone tries
to come to the slides they will get a
bullet to the face
in fact multiple you need to learn to
share no
no you kind of hide in the top
i'm shooting you in the balls just for
warning shots
don't try to get here what are you
defending the slide from
you you and you wait wait talk talk to
me while you're waiting guys
i'm dead guys it's mark he's got c4 on
the slide i do not
that is a lie he's got a c for a slide
yes boom ah no no no put your head up
mark no for a second i want to talk to
you
you've got to be kidding me oh god boom
where's zombie he's sneaking up on you
like a ninja where's the rogue element
oh he needs to get you with like one
shot shut up evp
showdown i've been waiting
i wasn't gonna shoot bob but you and
wade were coming up on me all scarily
i was in the right kind of
yeah bob told you guys zombie killed him
in cold blood why didn't you turn and go
to hit him i want to hold the slide it's
like a normal thing for a guy named
zombie to do i didn't think anything of
it
really greedy hogging the slides
yeah the real crime here is you hogging
the slide nothing right i
just wanted to talk about i'm going to
get the slide screw you guys the slide
is mine
no those are mine i'm going to get there
first you big jeff no i'm gonna get
there
first no i'm gonna get you if you get it
started i'm gonna kill you
no i think someone just like pounded on
my door
oh like for some reason i don't know
what probably part of those
noise complaints at the beginning noise
combined yeah
i've been starting to get noise
complaints recently oh my god i'm gonna
talk
oh so sensually into my mic this is how
i play now
apparently
i don't really care i'm moving out in
like two weeks
yeah screw those guys where you're
moving yeah exactly
that's true oh my gosh
i am very going to i'm gonna i'm gonna
be the
i'm gonna be the eye in the sky
commentator i'm leaving the slide forget
you guys i'm just gonna commentate on
all you guys
in a lyrically soft voice well it seems
that zombie mode has found an excellent
place to hide
away it seems that he's been scared from
his traitorous activities
bob is making his way around the
starting area you're looking for mark
are you so
quiet all of a sudden because i need to
be wait i'll crank up my
my uh
yes but to be honest it doesn't really
matter and it's only nine freaking
o'clock
what are these little like clear boxes
that i keep
i don't know maybe you should pick them
up
who did that the eye in this guy did not
see who did what
who's who's the eye in the sky who
didn't see what just happened
i did not see what happened mark i'm
bringing you a peace offering
i'm worried i am dead of course i'm dead
that's my body on the ground over there
oh i was killed by wade
my [ __ ] i didn't kill you i think wade
killed me
i think you're full of it i think wade
is full of bullets in about
10 seconds i will back mark up and say
wait did she merge yeah i believe that
way
yeah like a pews
well that was your mistake wade we all
believe that you were wrong
hey there's my dead body floating
towards me
you are suck at treating except for
bob
i really am gonna try to keep this voice
going for a while
you were so quiet i am quiet or i was
quiet
you are quiet no i'm not i'm coming in
loud and clear
no yes according to my readouts i am
bleeding so therefore you're not talking
like you normally do wait normally
you make your ears bleed yeah
okay sorry
all right enough of that i'm going back
to my normal voice because why are
everybody so quiet why do we have those
that's a really strange echoey voice
yeah thank you
i try real hard anyway i really it oh
all right
man i got to go up to the slide if
someone out there let me up there
um i don't want to do anything up there
just let me up the slide there's
something up there that i want to see
what are you going to do what happened
shot who shot who oh
why is that bullet fire coming towards
me
don't shoot shooting at you don't shoot
me move out of the way i need to get
through there
oh sorry matt yeah i'm going to that
that there's a wheel there turn that
wheel oh yeah can i touch
it touch it use it oh it's making noises
you hear that
oh i thought you were a terrorist oh i
thought that was like a terrorist only
use thing and you could use it
well that's a lie isn't there egg on my
face
obviously the terror is now a matter
what i'm silly what a silly [ __ ] that i
am wade nice to terrorist oh you all
wouldn't think that i'm the terrorist
oh it hurts so bad wade what is going on
over there i'm
getting shot by who i
don't know
my ankle
okay
over there bob that's bob bob are you
the terrorist tiger
killer mark was a terrorist i don't
think he was just the terrorist
oh did you kill me mug i didn't oh
yeah i did kill me again i thought you
were the terrorist
because he went up to this wheel i heard
buttons being pressed i thought that
territories could only use the buttons
god i thought okay that's why you have
negative 13. bob is definitely the
traitor and what the hell is latin doing
here
oh my gosh when did glenn get here oh my
gosh
all right wade you're very close to bob
you're very close to bob
oh check for closed doors
that you never close this way one opens
stop shooting at me zombie latin
i wasn't the bad guy i just kept getting
shot by everyone
oh okay i was pretty sure it was you
wade apparently latin has decided to
join us
yeah cheer on me
what is this baloney what is this what
are they burning themselves
what what
that was in that room no some
hot never mind there's some hot action
going on steamy
your eye in the sky is reporting they're
burning up in there
i guess
this got weird no not weird why would it
be weird
kind of weird it never gets weird in
these videos what do you mean
yeah that is definitely true we know oh
very sensitive nobody ever gets weird in
these videos
right we always keep it classified and
for pg friendly what is my karma
what did i ever 584 you killed everyone
like a total douche nugget i did not i
just killed
i don't know what you're saying
i know latin's here i don't know what
i'm gonna do now what if there's two
traders
what are we gonna do we're just gonna
assume that's me he's gonna can you
always
kill me now i won't kill you but
he promised i am not i i just
i promise i just wanna oh like that
means anything
wait i trust your innocence and mine let
us be innocent
can you trust me too and we team up hang
on no
let's touch sticks let us touch our
sticks in a sign of trust
oh jesus
that was good stick touching there thank
you
now what did you guys just do we touched
sticks
what does it sound like we did uh
hi yummy i'm not gonna shoot you hey
guys hey i want to touch my stick with
you
touch let's touch sticks yummy wait get
your stick out we're going to
chase yes i didn't make the jump it's
okay there's another way up
okay i'll i'll be there down here let's
all touch sticks down here ah there's
bullets
there's bullets who from where hey
wade get over here and get your stick
out and touch touch yummy sticks
from the showers touch yummy's stick
what is wrong with you guys in the
shower
no we're under the archway to the slide
i'm just saying mark i think weighs
stick is actually a bit bigger than
yours
for the shower god wade stop being such
a [ __ ]
let's keep your stick out and let's go
yeah what bob we're over here
bob you want to touch sticks i'm going
to go play with my stickers
it seems when you die your stick
disappears isn't that weird
everybody's ganging up on me maybe wait
never happened
we were your pals we touched sticks
uh oh oh my god
hi zombie you want to touch sticks
zombie
i just dropped my weapon you were my
friends
yummy where'd you go i was i'm playing
with my stick in the toilet
oh okay you want me to come help uh sure
yeah i need a little bit of um
a second hand over here
wade go oh no never mind